[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش كالعاده ابرز
ملفات اليوم في ملفاتي هذا المساء في قضيه
الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها لديهما من
الظالم ومن المظلوم بعيدا ام ترامب ام
السلطات الفدراليه الامريكيه في ملفنا
الثاني بقرار قضائي لماذا وضع طرابلس
نهايه لتعاون النفطي التركيين الليبي وما
هي سبل امام دبيبه واردوغاندي للالتفافي
على هذا القرار في الملف الثالث بعد صدور
الكتاب وتسريباته وحوارات الامير الصغير
التلفزيونيه هل نجح هابي في تغيير المشهد
الاعلامي كما كان يتمنى ام ان طلقاته
ارتدت الى صدره
[موسيقى]
فضيحه قد تطال الرئيس الامريكي والسبب
وثائقي سريه تعود الى الفتره التي كان
يشغل فيها منصب نائب الرئيس الاسبق باراك
اوباما ووفقا صحيفه واشنطوس فانه مسائله
قانونيه قد تطال بيض مستقبلا اذا دفع
جمهور مجلسا وبذلك البدايه كانت في نوفمبر
من السنه الماضيه عندما كشف محمد عن وثائق
السريه وجدت في مكتبي مركز الدبلوماسيه
والمشاركه العالميه بواسطه هذه الوثائق
التي اثارت جدلا وفتحت المجال امام
تساؤلات بخصوص
من عدمها راى فيها البعض فرصه ذهبيه
لترامب هذا الاخير وتسال عبر حسابه في
مناصره عما اذا كان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرا ليس يداهم منازل في اشاره منزله
في فلوريدا شبكه سينان من جهتها قالت ان
الوثائق التي لم يتم السريه عنها بعد يمكن
ان تخلف جدلا واسعا ويمكن ان تتسبب في
توجيه التخمه اساءه التعامل مع سجلات سريه
بالنسبه لبيض وايضا باثاره عاصفه سياسيه
خصوصا وان ما يحدث هو نفس السيناري الذي
حصل مع الرئيس الامريكي السابق عندما تم
العثور على وثائق سريه في منزله في
فلوريدا وهو موقف قد يدفع جمهوري مجلس
النواب والذي يتزعمه كذلك الى فتحي تحقيقا
بالغرض
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بكم
اهلا بكم
معك يا استاذ احمد استاذ احمد في الواقع
القانون الامريكي كما تعلم مع حضرتك
السريه مع انتهاء خدمتهم من لم يحدث
فما هو تفسيرك لذلك يعني هل هناك تعمد هل
هناك شبهه تعمد هل هناك ما الاسباب التي
تجعل منها هؤلاء ان يتمسك او ان يحتفظوا
بهذه همم هذه الوثائق
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله بنمسي عليكم على
ضيفك الكريم وعلى الاخوه المشاهدين طبعا
لا نستطيع ان نعرف بالضبط لماذا احتفظ اي
مسؤول باي وثائق وان كان غالبا هذا يعني
التفسير الاقرب يعني الاقرب للتصديق انه
خطا خطا سهو غير مقصود سواء كان في حاله
ايضا او في حاله تربه او في حاله اخرى
هناك مسؤولين كثيرين سابقين يعني يظهر
عندهم يعني بعض الوثائقي ينقلون وثائق الى
خارج المكاتب لاغراض العمل اللي بيشتغل
عليها بالليل او شيء مشابه ولكنه لا يتم
اعادتها عاده لا تنتهي بقضايا جنائيه قد
يكون هناك تاديب وظيفي قد يصل الى الفصل
في حاله الموظفين لكنه عاده لا يحدث هناك
يعني همم ملاحقه جنائيه الا اذا كان هناك
شبه التجسس المشكله في حاله ترامب انه رفض
اعاده الوثائق بينما بين الامير
لم يرفض هو همم تعامل يقول محاموه بانه
تعامل بطريقه ايجابيه مع همم جهات التحقيق
وهنا سؤال استاذ بشار يعني اذا ما وضعنا
الحالتين امام مقارنه نجد بان ترامب تم
الكشف عن هذا الوثائق همم بعد ان اخبر
احدهم هناك شيء تمت في تحركات الجهات على
اثرها للتحقيق ولمداهمه منزله ولكن بيض
محاموه انفسهم عندما حاولوا اخلاء مكان
كما قالوا في خزنه لايجاد مكان اخر لوضع
بعض الملفات عثروا على هذه الوثائق الباص
شكك في هذه الروايه في الواقع في داخل
الامريكي وقيل بانه وكان
سبق امكانيه ان يكون هناك فضح لهذا
الموضوع فحاول التعامل بايجابيه مع
الموضوع ما رايك
احسنت الطرح سيدتي لانه بالفعل هي المساله
كلها كيف يتعامل همم صاحب القرار في
الاداره مع الصحافه التي بدورها ستنق
روايته كما هي الى الراي العام الامريكي
البدايه في قضيه ترامب كانت ويشايه كان
هناك نوع من العمل الكيني كما اشرت في
عرضك للقضيه وهذا يشير الى ان هناك نيه
همم مسبقه ومبيته غير الايقاع بتراب وهذا
لا يحتاج الى دليل يعني هناك قضايا كثيره
من قضيه ضرائب كيف تعامل مع ملفات تعتبر
غير مسبوقه في الاداره الامريكيه خاصه
فيما يتعلق بمحاولته لتعرض ما يسمى بيتدخل
الدوله العميقه في قراره الخاصه بالبيت
الابيض ودور المؤسسات دور روابها
كل هذا تاكد الان لم يعد نظريه مؤامره ان
هناك نوع من التواضع كان بين كل ادوات
القوه هذه القوه الناعمه التي هتخجله في
المجتمع الامريكي بايديني يدرك واداره
بايديني يدرك ما هو بصدده ويعلم انه لا
يستطيع ان يسوق هذه الازدواجيه في
المعايير للصحافه خاصه بعد تم الكشف على
ان هذا الامر كان من المفترض ان يتم
تسريبه للصحافه في انتخابات التمهيديه مره
اخرى نعود الى دور الصحابه
ودورتك في التعدين على اخبار من شانها
احداث تغيير لدى الناخب الاميري هي القضيه
همم غلطت على بعض التفاصيل باختصار سيد
بشار
الصحافه الامريكيه لم تكن كما كلنا نعرفها
الصحافه الامريكيه اصبحت جزء من لعبه
السلطه في امريكا لذلك ترين كيف تم
التعامل الان مع قضيه اوراق السريه لاداره
بايجن في معياره مختلفه كليا حتى المعيار
واللاحظ ان مجرد واشد القوس عندما تقوم
بكشف هذه المساله بهذه الطريقه وكانه يريد
السباق بالفعل كما تفضل اخي الكريم من
هيوستن هو يريد استطباق كيفيه تعامل راي
العام الامريكي والصحافه الامريكيه مع هذه
انجاز التعبير الفضيحه وعليها استاذ احمد
هل هذه الشكليات او هذا
الاختلاف في الشكل في طريقه همم التعاطي
مع جهه التحقيق في طريقه تقديم الوثائق هل
يمكن ان تؤثر على مسار المساءله ان كانت
ستكون هناك بعيدا على على الاقل مسار
التعاطي مع هذه القضيه
القضيه المختلفتين تماما في حاله ترامب
عندما اكتشف وجود هذه الوثائق يعني كان
الارشيف الوطني طالبه اعاده الوثائق ورفضت
ربط اخذت العمليه سنه ونصف ما بين اول
مطالبه وما بين مداهمه منزل ترامب ايضا
مضت اشهر طويله لم يعرف الاعلام عن وجود
هذه الوثائق ولم يعرف الاعلام عن وجود هذه
المطالبات العمليه كانت مخفيه لفتره طويله
ولم تكشف الا بعد ان اصبح هناك اجراءات
قانونيه في حاله بايجن او ولد العمليه ترى
حديثه جدا يعني اكتشفت في اثنين نوفمبر
وتمت من وجدوا الوثائق على حسب يعني ما
قرانا في التقرير الاعلاميه انه من وجده
نعم او ابلغ الجهات المختصه مباشره
لدينا الوثائق هذه الوثائق يجب ان تسلم
للارشيف الوطني نريد ان نبدا في اجراءات
التسليم
الفرق كبير بين ان تذهب انت الاداره
المعنيه تقول ان هناك خطا يجب ان نصلحه
وانا ساتعاون معكم على اصلاح وبين ان
ترفضه الان هذا حقي ولن اسلم
الاستاذ احمد
يقول لك بانه هذا ما قدموش ولكن قد تخفى
امورما
القصه جديده جدا كما ذكرنا لم يكتشفها
الاعلام الا امس ولم تحدث اصلا بدايه الا
في اثنين نوفمبر قد نكتشف اشياء كبيره
لاحقا قد نكتشف حول طبيعه هذه الوثائق نحن
نعرف فقط ان هذه الوثائق مصنفه يعني عندما
يقال عن الوثائق انها مصنفه يعني انا سريه
ولكن هناك درجات عديده من السريه وهنا
يعني اسباب مختلفه للتصنيف هل هو وثائق
حساس فعلا امنا انها مصنفه فقط لا يوجد
فيها يعني هذا الاشخاص كل هذه الاحتمالات
وارده وسنعرف الكثير في المستقبل يعني كما
عرفنا عن الوطن نستطيع ان نعرف
مدى خطورتها ومتى يعني الاشكاليات
الموجوده فيها الا بعد اشهر طويله جدا
وبسبب دخوله هذه المحاكم بالتالي نحتاج
لمزيد من الوقت الاعلاميين يحتاجون مزيد
من الوقت لاجراء تحقيقاتهم الاجراءاتهم
ايضا وزاره العدل يعني المدعي العام تم
تحويل الموضوع لا هو سيفتح تحقيقه يعني
وكله فعلا احد المدعينين ترامب بالتحقيق
في القمر قد تكشف هذه التحقيقات جوانب لا
نعرفها الان تجعلنا نغير الصوره ولكن
الصوره حتى الان لا يوجد فيها اشكاليه
كبيره استاذ بشار هل هذه التفاصيل هي التي
ستؤثر على مسار التحقيقات ام ان كما يقول
ترامب يجب ان تكون هناك معامله بالمثل
وليس الكيل بمكيلين يجب كذلك ان تتحرك
السلطات المعنيه للقيام بمداهمه حضرتك
تعرف بان ترامب واتباعه
ومؤيدوه ترامب قفزه على هذه الفرصه هم
بالنسبه لهم فرصه من ذهب هل سيستغلوها
بالتاكيد لانه الان وجهه بيدن ووزير عدل
الى يساره في هذا السؤال من يوماكسه يعني
هو تساؤلات كلها مرتبطه ببعض لماذا يتم
الافصاح او تفجير هذه الفضيحه الاعلاميه
الان لماذا يضطر الان الرئيس بايدن زياره
الحدود مع المكسيك وزياره المكسيك بعد ولا
ولا يستطيع ان يغيب الصوره التي ترتبط
ارتباطا جذريا بخمسه التحقيقات يقوم
الكونجرس الجديد مجلس النواب بالقياده
الجمهوريه الان خاصا بقياده اليمين
المحافظ بالحزب الجمهوري بالتحقيق بخمسه
ملفات من ضمنها دور وزاره العدل الامريكيه
والتسييس الذي اتهمت به في قضايا كثيره
عندما يطرح ترامب بان لماذا لا تتم
مداهمات على غرار ما تم في قضيه في مره جو
اعتقد ان هذا الشيء مبرر لانه من الناحيه
التحقيقيه
الاستاذ احمد يقول بانه هناك تفسير
للموضوع
تعامل مع السلطات وهو من او محامو من
قدموا هذه الوسائل
نتسائل لماذا كل هذه الصدف التي تتغير
عندما تقترب الامور من انتخابات اولا
وثانيا من امكانيه اعاده ترشيح بايدي
لنفسه هذه التساؤلات اعتقد محقه على الاقل
بنسبه لانك صحفيين يعني الصحافه الامريكيه
المشهوره بالتحقيقات الصحفيه وبكشف الكثير
من المستور من القضايا الساخنه دوليا هل
تعجز عن التعامل مع قضيه
قد تنفع بايضا قد تبرزته همم التي تتعامل
بصدق مع الجماهير ومع المؤسسات الفيدراليه
اكثر من انها قد تؤذيه
ريم ساتفق مع هذا الطرح تماما اذا تعامل
مع هذه الشفافيه في التحقيقات الخمسه خاصه
موضوع وزاره العدل والاف بي اي وقضيه
هانتر بايجن ليه تروحون على الشفافيه التي
انتظرها العالم لماذا يقوم هنتر بايدل
بصفقات تتعلق بالغاز وهو في الصين
واوكرانيا وهو لا يقتل اوكرانيه ولا
الصينيه ولا علاقه له على الاطلاق في كل
مسيرته المهنيه في قضيه وملف الطاقه
والغاز ويقنعون لماذا تم التواطئ بين الاف
بي اي وبين تويتر وبين طافه في امريكا
على هذا الملف
وضحت فقره حضرتك استاذ بشار ولكن خليني
اسال ضيفي في هذا الاطار هل تتفق استاذ
احمد مع ان اا هذه الصدف لا يمكن ان تاتي
بطريقه اعتباطيه وكذلك هناك من يؤيد ترامب
ويشير الى انحياز السلطات الفيدراليه
لبيضن في هذا الاطار
في تعامل السلطات بين يعني قضيه ملفات
وقضيه ملفات ترامب حتى الان حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يوجد اي اختلاف سيحدث الاختلاف
اذا ما خرجت السلطات الفيدراليه وقالت ان
هناك مزيد من الوثائق يجب تسليمها ورفض
بيضه تسليمها ثم تصرفت فيما بعد ذلك
باسلوب يختلف عن ما تصرفت فيه مع احترامي
حتى الان لا يوجد اختلاف ظهور هذه القصه
في هذا الوقت تحديدا ليس من
صالحه للرئاسه هذه القصه لا يمكن ان تقدم
هي قد تكون قد تضره وقد لا تضره على حسب
ما يتكشف لاحقا لكنها لن تخدم وبالتالي
ليس من صالح كشفيه في هذا الوقت والاعلام
يعني كشفها لانه لم يراعي مصلحه فائده
الاعلام يبحث خبر وحقق فيه ونشره
هل هو مفيده مضر
على كل انسان تبقى هناك متابعه سنحاول ان
نفهم كيف ستكون الامور مع كشف اكثر تفاصيل
ناخذ هذا الموضوع ساكتفي معكم بهذا القدر
ولكن اشكركما جزيل الشكر على الحضور
والمشاركه من واشنطن بشر جرار الكاتب
المحللات السياسي ومن هيوستن احمد الحنطي
الباحث في شان الامريكي شكرا لكم